so welcome to this intelligence Square
debate with Henry dimbleby whose modest
ambition is to save both our health and
our planet
and he is co-founder of Leon the
director of the sustainable Restaurant
Association he was the government's
foods are at defra where he published
this widely acclaimed national food
strategy before quitting in frustration
and I have to say I have read to your
strategies as you know there are very
few government papers that I read back
to back and keep by myself yours is one
uh he will also co-opered the school
food plan and I have eaten your school
food which transforms what children eat
at school and your new book is ravenous
how to get ourselves and our planet into
shape which has the most fantastic
picture of quite an edible donut I think
although it could have been a bagel and
it is also in the Sunday Times
bestseller list only beaten by the air
for our cookbooks which we are going to
ignore
um so your next book as you say it's
going to be an air fryer book
who in the best sellers list at once but
thank you very much for joining us and
our event tonight is going to run for an
hour
I'm going to ask questions for about 40
minutes 45 minutes and then it's over to
the audience to ask questions and
you can start asking them now actually
by clicking on the ask question button
underneath the video screen and then you
type in your question if you want your
name to be mentioned type it in the box
then press send and I will try to
remember to mention it and if you feel
as anything at all that I have not
covered feel free to go for it you'll
probably have much better questions and
I will look at them at the end and go
through as many as possible
um I think we can start very soon the
audience are supposed to be using the
hashtag
iq2 to tweet if you can tweet through
the process
um probably Henry and I will have to
focus on what we're talking about
um so we could start now
um
I really want to start by saying that
food has just become so complicated for
most of us um and the Ft said this
weekend that no one knows what a healthy
breakfast is anymore that you know
you've got little chickens have the
avian flu the eggs are costing a fortune
bacon is injected with sodium nitrate
then fruit juices contain all these
sugars nuts and muesli have flown from
around the world you know do you have
almond milk do you have oat milk it's
quite difficult so what do you eat for
breakfast Henry
um
well I guess this morning I had for
breakfast some sourdough taste with
sauerkraut on it but my wife thinks this
is absolutely disgusting but I I
normally have actually funny enough
uh quite continental breakfast so I'll
have tomatoes chickpeas coffee whatever
whatever's in the fridge
um which is ridiculously on brand but it
also happens to be true and do you ever
have an Egg McMuffin or have you never
had one of those
I so funnily enough when I was a child I
used to like Burger King rather than
McDonald's and one of the reasons that
we set up Leon was because both John and
I used he used to like McDonald's ice
like Burger King and uh we remembered
the excitement of those restaurants when
we were kids you both of us used to
before term go out to us a movie and
then go and have fast food
um but recently when I've had McDonald's
it is your palette kind of moves away
from that and it is you know you could
eat the thing that you about it you can
eat it with your gums without your teeth
and the sweetness of the bread I just
find pretty unpalatable
um
at this stage in life
I think written the national food
strategy
do you really understand that why the
British have such a peculiar attitude to
food we sort of lost the plot we can't
take it seriously we don't pay enough
for it why specifically is it America
and Britain that seem to have done so
badly
well you know in in it's American
Britain Germany a bit behind I think
that the story of the UK there are kind
of a few overlaying things and if you
want to understand how different the UK
is from say France and Spain 50 seven
percent of the of the food that we eat
is highly processed France and Spain
sorry Italy and Spain it's kind of in
the low teens and France is slightly
higher above that so we do eat a very
different diet I think it it goes back
to first of all uh the Industrial
Revolution so when uh we we basically
moved our citizens into Towns at the end
of the 19th century
France by contrast had about the same
percentage of their population in towns
uh as we did at the end of the 19th
century in the early 60s so they stayed
near where their food was grown for much
longer and at the same time because we'd
moved the labor out of the fields we
then imported much more of our own food
so we by the beginning of the second
world war only had 30 only produced 30
percent of our own food it's much more
now we produce over 60 of our own food
um so we dislocated our population from
the countryside and
this is from that point there are all
politicians basically from that point
through the Burr War and the first world
war were very worried about how bad our
diet is periodically they've intervened
because the poor were not able to eat
good food they were eating bread and tea
uh and other things and then I think the
second thing that happened is
um we that we created because we were
more American we were more Market driven
we created this kind of super-powered uh
food
industry that has
really turned up the dial and we could
talk about this a bit later in terms of
how it markets and sells as food and
that didn't happen in the same way in in
southern Europe so I think there are a
kind of combination of historical
factors and then a culture that meant
the government in other countries in
Japan and South Korea and Spain and
France the government have tried to do
more to
encourage a good food culture than we
have in this country I was going to ask
you why you thought in the last year
when inflation's gone up gone up by you
know 16 food inflation how that has
affected people has it made them
eat more sensibly or do you think
actually it's exacerbated the problem
because people are just looking for very
cheap ways of feeding their families
well we don't know we don't know is the
answer so we don't we haven't got good
data on how diets have shifted but what
we do know is that in a cost of living
crisis
um food is typically the the first thing
to go so when you have your fixed costs
and your household your your
um your rent or your mortgage and your
heating bills and so forth it is the
reason there is what people call Food
poverty is is not because it's anything
other than poverty but it's because food
is the thing that people can Skip and
the the one piece of data that we have
seen is that more houses which is now
measured by by the government more
houses more people are skipping meals as
a result of uh of financial constraints
and I would ex you would expect in that
in that scenario to see what happens if
you look at diets across the piece diets
are pretty bad across the piece but
there is a skew to poor diet uh in
people who haven't got a lot of money
and that tends to be because for example
uh they
uh and there's good data on this you
know if you haven't got a lot of money
and you want to feed your family you
want to feed them something that you
know that they will eat do you want to
go for the Blockbusters because you
can't afford to feed your children for
example healthily and then if they don't
like it feed them something else so we
know that the cost of living has
increased the number of people skipping
meals we don't know uh yet whether it's
changed what they eat but we would
expect it to uh to make diets slightly
worse
what about the war in Ukraine because in
some ways that may have helped and that
we've had to start looking at our own
food so I know the government said let
them eat turnips but there is a sense
where we might actually start eating a
bit more healthily if we do look around
locally for local produce rather than
relying on food flying in yeah I mean I
found the the whole debate about whether
it is acceptable to ask people to eat
more turnips incredibly frustrating so
there there is if you step right back
the reason that Ukraine is so important
it's because it has incredibly fertile
soil and we have a population
on the planet now that exists in areas
where the soil in that area would be
unable to feed the population of that
country so for example Egypt which
Imports a lot of wheat from Ukraine even
if you farmed it incredibly intensively
the land in Egypt would only be able to
support the population it's like less
than half the population
and that is because we've got very good
at Distributing and storing food so that
is a decision that we have made maybe
subconsciously as a as a race that we
will move food from productive areas to
unproductive areas
here in the UK we are actually pretty
[Music]
um
protected from that because we have
pretty productive soil we produce about
60 of our own food if we had to and the
department of environment food and Rural
Affairs did a study on this we could
quite quickly ramp up our own product
production to to feed the whole
population from British soil if we ate
Less meat because it's inefficient
so what actually I think you're seeing
at the moment the the real underlying
thing obviously Wars are bad and if you
are Egypt that is concerning there are
things that we talk about that Egypt
might be thinking about in the future in
the book but for us I think the biggest
worry is climate change so
um the food system is by far the biggest
cause of the destruction of Nature and
after energy it is the the second
biggest cause of climate change it emits
20 to 30 of greenhouse gases and what we
saw earlier this year in Morocco which
was a failure of a kind of weird freak
weather event uh that is going to happen
more often uh and the way that we eat is
actually imperiling the way we eat so
um we shouldn't be talking about whether
we can eat turnips in in whether it's
okay to tell people to eat turnips in
Winter what we should be thinking about
is how can we make our food system less
Environmental destructive and it might
not just be you know that that Moroccan
event was quite
mild but if you look at say rice
um
the the biggest exporter of rice to the
world is the Mekong Delta half of which
will be underwater if sea levels rise a
meter so for me
um the big issue with food security is
climate and biodiversity and that's what
we should be focusing on not whether
it's okay for a minister to tell people
to eat turnips which is very funny uh
you know it's a good debate but it's not
particularly relevant
whatever you like about your book is
that how to get yourself and the planet
into shape is actually the same way
isn't it it's not they're not actually
pulling against each other so the fact
that we eat 57 of our food is all um
deeply uh unnutritious and fast food is
also the way that we are wrecking the
planet so what are we actually doing to
our bodies when we're eating that kind
of food because you write about it very
well how are we destroying them well
it's not entirely overlapped so I'm sure
we might come into this so I do make the
argument that the fact that so much meat
is eaten in processed form that you
could
substitute
uh meat and processed products for other
kinds of protein and you wouldn't
improve our health but you would
massively improve the impact on the
environment but in terms of our health
there is the the one of the oldest uh or
eight most ancient pieces of evolution
our body is the amygdala in the brain
which actually evolved in prehistoric
Marine worms
and this drives our most
fundamental desires and appetite and it
is where appetite where the hormones of
appetite meet the brain and and affect
our Behavior and we talk in the book
about how powerful this is this urge and
we give the example of the Chilean rugby
players in who are documented very well
by Pierce Paul Reed in his book alive uh
who crashed in the in the Andes and ran
out and they survived amazingly ran out
of food and the urge to eat was so
strong that uh they ended up eating
their family and friends first their
flesh which they cut from the bodies
with the glass from the windows of the
plane uh and then their organs there and
then their lungs and then their brains
so our appetites will make us do
extraordinary things and this processed
food that we currently the 57
most of that is designed in such a way
that it uh is irresistible to that
appetite that appetite evolved to make
us go to quite Great Lengths to seek out
highly calorie dense food and when we
eat that food it fills up less often and
it uh less quickly and we eat more of it
and companies spent more and more money
uh marketing that food and developing it
we've eaten more and we've got sick and
that sickness to answer your question uh
there is uh part of it is just
overweight and the the the the weight
that that puts uh the the pressure that
puts on your body and that can create
Cancers and diabetes
um heart disease
but actually the quality of the food and
the way in which it messes around for
example with our insulin production
means that in the States now where forty
percent of people are
pre-diabetic they're a significant
number of what they call the skinny ill
so people who have diabetes without
being overweight because of the way this
very sugary fatty food interacts with
our our bodies and fun enough those are
the people if you're diabetic and you're
skinny you're more likely to to dive it
than if you're overweight because uh
because you don't you know you don't
spot that you're that you're sick
is that two to one ratio that you talk
about about breast milk which is so true
isn't it the idea that yeah just
perfectly formulated for ice cream
um
there's a two to one there's a ratio of
sugar to Fat salt and there are various
different ones in in breast milk the
ratio is uh two two sugar one fat and
that is particularly it's a bliss point
and it's in ice cream funnily enough
it's also in crisps if you take the
carbs to be the the sugar and it's in
all sorts of foods and actually the the
work of the of Kevin Hall who was the
first person to prove in the states that
this old processed food was really bad
for us he has now identified
specific ratios that really of carbs to
Fat to salt that don't exist in
unprocessed food so there is something
about this food that literally
interacts with this this uh marine worm
brain this most fundamental part of our
of our kind of drive to live that that
is that is causing causing a lot of
trouble and causing us harm and it's not
but it's not just you know we talk in
the book it's not just ask we're stuck
in the junk food cycle those food
companies
if they decided not to do that
individually the CEOs they would just
lose share to another food company or be
fired so it's it's a systemic problem
this commercial this reaction between
the commercial incentive of companies
and and this ancient evolved appetite
and the problem is it's like an
addiction really isn't it but unlike say
cigarettes or alcohol or gambling you
can you can't really live without it so
it's not like you can go cold turkey and
just not eat anything at all that's the
problem is that you have to learn to
live with it and to eat it and to eat
sensibly and what you come up with
Solutions what kind of solutions can the
government come up with them they
obviously haven't come up with enough
but stuff like portion control is really
important how do you
get companies to to produce the right
portion controls
well it's it it's very difficult and you
know if you look for example the new
wave of uh uh of attack on this appetite
is the delivery companies and it is very
hard for them
to give us
portions that would be reasonable and
there's good evidence that we could we
overeat massively when we eat delivered
food uh it's very hard for them to give
us portions that would be reasonable
because uh we would complain that they
weren't big enough but basically there
are two ways that you can tackle the
health problem
if the the feedback loop that's going
wrong is the feedback between our
appetite and the commercial incentives
of companies you can tackle you can
change either of those so to change the
commercial incentives companies there
are all sorts of things you can do you
can restrict advertising you can put
into place
reformulation taxes you can restrict
what can be marketed to children just to
just to improve the environment a bit
better and uh we argue in in the book
that that is what you should do but we
also
recognize
that uh what I think is actually more
likely to happen is that government will
think that stuff's a bit tricky that's
politically difficult I don't want to
Nanny State etc etc and they will focus
on the appetite and there are
very good drugs now or very effective
drugs at restricting our appetite uh
semi-glutide is the name of the drug its
brand name is mpic it's suddenly been in
the press a lot over the last few weeks
and
basically you inject yourself once a
week and you feel less hungry and if you
are a someone who has struggled with
weight all of your life you have a BMI
of over 30 you are very unwell
I think that those you know you should
go to your GP you should look at that
option but I what I think is going to
happen is that the government will
whichever government will think actually
fixing the underlying problems too hard
and 20 million uh people will end up
permanently on these drugs there's been
reports in the paper recently that Steve
Barkley our current health secretary has
already asked for a paper about how much
it would cost to uh to give this drug to
12 million people and there are there
are problems with that there are two two
problems I have for that one is when you
give drugs to that many people the side
effects can uh can scare people you have
very slow level of side effects as we
have with the vaccine which make the
drug scary to people which means that
people who might actually benefit from
it don't want to take it but the other
one is more fundamental which is
are the hormones of appetite do because
they evolved have all sorts of other
roles in in our body they they used to
balance all sorts of different uh
biological processes in our body and I
want I think there is a fundamental
concern about using a drug that focuses
on a certain hormone glp1 in this case
and basically
makes you artificially release more of
it uh dealing with a complex system in
that way I think you inevitably will
cause
uh unintended side effects down the line
I think it's a really really dangerous
way to solve the problem of a bad food
system
it's also
that sense that you're not going to
enjoy food anymore so the people who are
on it don't actually really enjoy eating
anymore so you lose that sense of eating
for pleasure and enjoyment as well as
you know to get your nutrients and I
think that that in the long term is
rather sad because I think it's one of
the aspects that people do enjoy you
really love food you know we love
cooking that sense that that you're
being forced to eat less because you
can't really be able to you can't
control yourself in any way yeah yes I
mean
I'd be quite careful not to impose my
values but definitely you know the
uh instinctively I think God that's not
a world that I would like to live in
um and in fact in the you mentioned uh
up front I don't work for the government
before on school food and one of the
things I did was help write the
curriculum and I was really pleased that
we managed to sneak in there that
um the lessons should try and instill a
Love of Cooking which is one of the
great Outlets of human creativity into
the curriculum
but I trying to kind of fight against
that though those values of mine you
know I spoke to
a few people who are on semiglutide and
one of whom we quote in the book who um
who said she doesn't enjoy food as much
but her whole life had been a struggle
with food and she just feels released
from that struggle I should then rather
rudely said you should try it
but but I but you know you have I do
think there are people if you look at
the bell curve of Sadia our appetites
are very different and so if you are a
naturally thin person you have to
imagine how you feel at the end of a
death by mistake you didn't eat for the
day and realize that other people feel
that
when they've eaten you know uh
relatively recently so we all have
different appetites and I do think if
someone has a particularly strong
appetite if they have a genetic
propensity to obesity is somewhere
between 40 and 70 percent for those
people I can see what would be a bleak
existence for me might seem like a
blessed relief
so I did quite a lot of research on the
food in Japan which is also in your book
where they they did have quite an
overweight Nation after the second world
war when they were introduced to
American food and twinkies and
chips and burgers and they did grow a
bit like we have in the way that we now
have we've gone from one percent being
obese in the 50s now to sort of 30 and
they did crack it by having very much a
nanny state but almost food rationing
that they went back to telling people
what to eat the children all had to eat
the same things at food do you think we
could ever get to that situation in
Britain whereas instead of taking drugs
actually what we do is say to people
this is how you need to eat
yes although I wouldn't put it quite
like that but I think we can change our
food culture
so people say well why can't you know
why how can we get people eating cooking
from scratch can we get people eating
better food can we change our culture
and go people go no no it's possible the
Genies out of the bottle that's never
gonna happen but actually
it's happened here
we have created and changed our food
culture and as you say it's happened in
Japan so Japan's been through you know
we all think of the Japanese
um
uh food culture as being kind of
god-given amazing food and they have
four percent of their population as a
beast
uh they have changed their food culture
twice
first of all in the Meiji period the
Meiji restoration when they opened up to
foreigners and they saw all these
um hulking Dutch traders who were the
first people to trade with them because
they were the only ones being pragmatic
Dutch people they were the only ones who
would stand on the Bible to to sign
deals uh and the Chinese came in and
they thought my God these people are so
strong we need to do something about it
so the the emperor first of all decided
that he would eat red meat and be public
about it which was taboo at the time
they got the Army to they created a
whole new menu for the Army
um which included dishes that they stole
from all around the world katsu curry
for example was taken from a fried
chicken dish with an Indian curry sauce
that was served on British naval ships
and then they got those
um Cooks in the uh in the Army and the
Navy be to broadcast on radio cookery
lessons for for Japanese houses
and then after the war
they had a similar thing again so they
actually they went from again being very
starved and MacArthur came in they they
uh they as you said the diet began to
become quite American but then they
really turned up the dial on creating a
Japanese food culture so
um both subtly so for example
um they had quite restrictive
agricultural rules to try and maintain
this new Japanese cultural diet they
have planning rules that uh that meant
it was quite hard for fast food chains
to set up there but then they also had
the Metabo law which meant that still
you get measured by your company once a
year and if you are overweight you you
get you get uh you know a bit of help
from a dietitian and a bit of advice so
you can I think change through cultures
and I think will in this country in the
end
I think we will realize that we need to
we've done it quite recently you know we
when I was a journalist in the 90s
um I I was we just had the first time
out food Awards and we'd had the eagle
Gastropub had opened and quaglino's had
opened and I was sent by the telegraph
to go and compare British food to French
food and I traveled uh you know on the
ferry then across to Paris like and
actually except for about four
restaurants in in
um London all the food was better in
France I repeated that Journey the other
day and we are now and I I can I would
categorically defend this to anyone who
wants to to have an argument we are now
we have a better we have better
restaurants than the French the French
have not improved since the 90s they've
sat on their Laurels and I really do
think that that culture can permeate
down that we can find a food culture in
the UK and that we can learn to cut from
scratch but in the meantime you've still
got this 57 of food that's processed so
I think that's kind of two transitions
that need to happen one is we need to
make the process stuff less
uh less bad and then the other is we
need to focus on
from the bottom up creating a better
culture of cooking and uh uh cooking
from scratch and feeding our families
and eating together Etc and I don't
think that that is nuts I think cultures
change all the time
and that's what's so difficult and I was
I did restaurant reviews at the
telegraph I think when you were there
that um for 10 years and the food did
change dramatically but what didn't was
the discussion around farming actually
and now we've got a huge discussion
going on about whether we want rewilding
whether we want to keep the big Agri
Farms we've got all the new trade deals
going through and there is a sense that
we could actually have more regenerative
farming we could have more sustainable
farming and then we could teach people
to eat with local produce and from these
farms and do you think there's any way
we're getting closer to that now or not
I think the farming side is really
exciting so you know basically in the
book we say the health problem is caused
by this junk food cycle this feedback
loop that's going wrong between appetite
and and Commercial incentives of
companies I think that is tricky to
break the reason that our farming has is
so destructive is that uh what what the
economist path had asked up to called
the invisibility of nature we don't
measure nature in any of the systems
that we use to to measure human success
so uh you can't count nature in a wallet
it's not in the balance sheet of
companies it's not in the way we measure
GDP and in fact Jessica points out that
it's not just not there we actually
subsidize globally activities that
destroy nature governments do to the
tune of about 500 billion dollars a year
through subsidies to agriculture to
fishing and to fossil fuels
so
we have an opportunity the one the kind
of one thing that that about brexit that
almost everyone agrees on
is that we have who knows about it is
that we have an opportunity to change
that in the UK because we're coming out
of the common agricultural policy so we
have an opportunity to pay people not to
destroy nature but to restore it to give
payments for public goods uh and I think
and currently the framework the
government has is the right one there
are all sorts of ways that it could go
wrong and if you want we can talk about
how it needs to go right but but
fundamentally we have an opportunity to
show the world that this is possible the
only thing that is or there are lots of
things that are difficult about it but
the one thing already that has gone
slightly wrong is trade deals because
it makes no sense to incentivize our
Farmers to farm differently
uh and then allow Imports of of food
that is grown to lower standards for a
broad effectively you're just moving
though moving the problems to a country
where you can't see them and in the
Australian trade deal uh
uh probably the worst trade deal any
country has ever done according to the
Australian press who Amazed by um how
bad it was uh the in that Trader that
did not protect our Farmers now it might
not matter with the Australian trade
deal because most of their food anyway
for economic reasons goes to China and
is not sold into this Market but if we
do similar trade deals with America and
Brazil and so forth uh we could hobble
our own attempt to show the world how
it's possible to farm in a in a more
nature friendly fashion
foreign